why are you so confused this [ __ ] is so
simple you have to give give give give
give give give give it has never been
more practical to be a good person in
the history of life it has never ever
been more practical than right this
second to be somebody that gives because
of the way communication is now
structured in our society that the
ability from everybody to distribute it
is in play and that the truth and karma
has never been more practical powerful
groups these my friends step up and
start doing more good please understand
that doing the right thing
behind the scenes not publicly tweeting
your donations to look good or showing
concern because it's the right thing to
do in a tweet know stuff that people
don't safety do the right thing right
now do the good do the truth give the
goods because the practicality and the
strength or the leverage historically
and the leverage that you're building
for your life and the fact is somebody
in Oakland somebody in everybody is
always watching always give give give
and then if you need to ask understand
that the key to the give give give
strategy is zero expectations so many of
you are giving and giving and giving
with the thought of what you're gonna
get in return and my friends that is not
giving that snip Y elated the outcome
and that will also be exposed because it
all will because that's what's playing
out wrap your head around what
technology is doing it is doing slightly
light my friends is bringing light to
the shadows of the game and this is why
the good the giving the providing value
has never been important that dollar a
the strategy that I put out an Instagram
that's so many people winning form so
many of your winning from right now do
you understand that it works for the
little the people that only have 80
followers but it works even more even
more for the big so many of you have
such big platforms please use them to
give to you and publicly like I do
blending that this kind of content will
three do your thing you can entertain
copy and music and entertaining skits
bring so much now you bring me escapism
to other people letting them to take
their mind off the troubles I believe in
that [ __ ] so much but please also leave
those comments leave those teams read
your emails pick somebody every day do
something financially emotionally giving
has never been more practical I've never
been more powerful because the depths of
how it can be reached and passed on and
the stories being told a greater than
ever
word-of-mouth infrastructure is at the
core of the social media revolution the
evolution of the Internet itself right
now and everything is being exaggerated
everything Beauty skills darkness and
light
and beyond that you please give if you
can something or daily